I'm wondering what would be the single
most valuable piece of advice you give
us to even attempt to create some of the
value that you guys have done in both
your very impressive companies people
say you you have to have a lot of
passion for what you're doing and it's
totally true and the reason is is
because it's so hard that if you don't
any rational person would give up it's
really hard and you have to do it over a
sustained period of time so if you don't
love it if you're not having fun doing
it you don't really love it you're gonna
give up and that's what happens to most
people actually if you really look at
that the ones that ended up you know
being successful unquote in the eyes of
society and the ones that didn't
oftentimes it's the ones that are
successful loved what they did so they
could persevere when it you know when it
got really tough and and the ones that
didn't love it quit because they're
saying right who would want to put up
with this stuff if you don't love it so
it's a lot of hard work and and it's a
lot of worrying constantly and if you
don't love it you're gonna fail so you
got to love it you got to have passion